- Yes.
It's my favorite.
We own the airport.
And that guy, sorry.
(energetic music)
(soft music)
Friday morning, Chicago.
The W.
Gorgeous outside.
Three hardcore meetings.
A schlep from Chicago
to the Milwaukee Airport
for a quick meeting and
probably not a whole lot
of filming for you, Babin,
so I'm gonna have to
come up with some sort of huge rant.
Vlog, some days are just boring for you
because they're exciting for
me 'cause I get to be the CEO
of the motherfucking marketing company
of the future and present,
they just don't know yet.
(soft music)
Sneakers are selling crazy on eBay.
'Sup, vlog.
Going into meeting number one.
Big fortune 100 company in Chicago.
Babin can't come.
Ryan can come.
(soft music)
Why are you stealing my clothes?
- We're staying.
(soft music)
(distant conversation)
- Dark Horse, big one?
(soft music)
(distant conversation)
Get some micro content, here.
Oh, you wanna be in it?
Oh.
(he laughs)
- No, I think that's fine.
(soft music)
- Just not used to that.
Or Babin's pumped with
you because he finally,
now he has an episode.
He has an episode.
- We're back live with Gary Vaynerchuk,
Tyler Babin, Marcus, can't even--
- [Gary] Krzastek.
- Krzastek and Gary Vee.
Who is your idol in the
entrepreneurship business world?
- Nobody.
Nobody.
But, I will say this.
- Yeah.
- Well, because I never spend
time digging into anybody.
I always really stay
to the small, you know,
I was 34 years old when I kind of came out
to the regular world 'cause
I was in the liquor business
in a family business in New Jersey.
Met no one.
We talk about this all the time.
I lived in this weird cocoon so I never,
and I wasn't a good student or a reader.
I had no network.
I didn't even know.
I was so grossly undereducated,
that I didn't even know
to idolize anybody.
I idolized my parents.
I'm a nine, I always tell everybody,
I'm a 1950s immigrant much more
than, you know what I mean?
- [Man] Okay.
- We lived very weird so nobody.
That being said, I will say this.
I really do admire Richard Branson
and I don't know a lot about him,
so I'm gonna hedge it a little bit
but intuitively, the path of
building actual businesses
while actually building a persona as well,
and the, kind of, the way
that he made those two work,
I think is something that I'm up to
and so I gravitate towards that.
- [Man] Alright.
Electric chair meal.
You have one meal to go.
What's the meal you eat?
- White Castle burgers.
(soft music)
- Yes.
It's my favorite.
We own the airport.
And that guy, sorry.
(laughter)
- [Babin] Why did we bring
the girl from Chicago--
- Right so, good job, Babin.
Way to go on the set-up so here we are
in the empty Milwaukee Airport
and gonna be home four hours later
because the big potential
client had a change of plans
and was like, let's
get together in January
and sometimes you have to hack
because no time like the present, right?
Meeting in January in the
corporate business world means
maybe we'll do something in the summer,
maybe we'll do something in 2019.
Meeting in October, or
excuse me, November,
means you could do something in 2018
so when that feedback came back,
I said, fuck it, let's take
a three hour, two hour,
actually that'd be an hour and a half.
But a two hour drive and
we'll come to Milwaukee
and we'll have a meeting in the Starbucks
and then we'll go on our merry way
so I get back to New
York four hours later,
which is not a preference
on a Friday night
but reality is is the
opportunity to strike was there
and these are the decisions between
work life balance, right?
I'm weighing do I wanna get
home couple hours earlier
on a Friday night and
so I thought about it,
well the kids are actually gonna be in bed
one way or the other so I
lose out on that variable
and Lizzy and I are grown-ups.
We could stay up later and
the Jets have a bi-week
this Sunday, so I'm
gonna be more all in on,
and so, those are some
of the stuff in the,
that's how I made the decision of let's,
'cause the schlepping and
the hardcore and sleep,
like that stuff's easy.
I'll grind, I'm dirt.
I'm dirt.
I'll do anything, any time, always.
Humility to the fucking max.
I'm fuckin' absurdly
passionate and romantic
about three hours drives and
fuckin' two minute meetings
in the fuckin' gutter.
I'll meet you in the forest
if I think it's ROI positive
so I don't need to be fancy, you know?
I just need to get it done
in my work life environment.
(announcer speaking on telecom)
That's why we're in Milwaukee.
Big up, Brewers.
We're only fingers in the fucking house.
I actually love this.
It's the best.
I mean, not to visit, no no no no.
Where's my--
Guys I never forget, I don't
know what just happened.
I almost wanna look back at the film
'cause I have such a system.
By the way, fun fact, 'cause this is
becoming an interesting episode.
The system is if you can get to a place
where you always pat your pants,
I always pat my pants and I
make sure I have everything.
I don't know what I patted.
I guess, maybe the mic.
I did something that made me think,
I don't know what the hell just happened.
Anyway.
(exhales)
(soft music)
Found a little opening here, so.
Vlog, I'm about to go live.
Set your notifications.
Oh, if you're wondering,
we haven't transformed it
to Airport Gary yet because
we have to have the meeting.
Good afternoon, good afternoon.
Good afternoon, Instagram.
Good to see you.
Ryan Harwood is here, CEO of PureWow.
- Hey.
How's it goin'?
- What do you got to say for yourself?
- Are you live right now?
- I'm live.
- Uh, we're in Milwaukee.
- No no no, you shouldn't have,
now people are gonna show up.
End video.
(he laughs)
(soft music)
Alright Milwaukee, the best
part of today's episode.
It is time for your favorite
superhero in the world.
(laughter)
Airport.
(energetic music)
(he laughs)
Alport Guy?
- Alport Guy.
Alport Guy!
- It's Alport Guy.
Alright, fans.
Have a good weekend.
We've already had it is--
(background noises drown out Gary)
Good.
In focus.
Oh, actually.
(energetic music)